here in germany a suspect is in custody
after a mass stabbing
three people died from their wounds and
at least five others were seriously
injured
police say they're investigating a
possible islamist terror motive
witnesses said the man shouted the
islamic phrase alawa
the attack took place in the southern
state of bavaria in a plaza in the
centre of the city of wurzburg
pedestrians tried to stop the attacker
and may have prevented more bloodshed
the knife man struck in the historic
center of wurzburg
which was crowded with shoppers on a
sunny afternoon
authorities say the attacker was a 24
year old somali man with a history of
mental illness
witnesses said he started stabbing
people for no apparent reason
but was confronted by passers-by
we saw him he had a really big knife and
was attacking people
and then people tried to throw chairs or
umbrellas or cell phones at him to stop
him
but none of that worked
then the police approached him and a
shot was fired
you could hear that clearly in any case
they caught him
police shot the man in the leg before
arresting him
there's no indication that any other
perpetrator is involved
we have arrested one suspect who is now
being held in custody
he suffered a firearm wound
officials say the attacker was known to
have violent tendencies
and was undergoing compulsory
psychiatric treatment
police at the scene were quick to
reassure the public that there was no
further danger
the various premiere says the state is
grieving for the victims
and their families
dw reporter elizabeth yan is in wurzburg
elizabeth has any new information
emerged about the victims
well so far we have very little
information about the victims
uh all we can say at the moment is that
it seems that they were at the wrong
place at the wrong time
um we we know that among
those who are still uh wounded there is
a little boy but
whether how many people still remain in
critical condition
we don't know at this point and what
about the suspect do we have any more
information on him
well again we know that he was a is a 24
year old
man of somalian citizenship who had been
living here in wurzburg
for a couple of years but recently
showed
symptoms of mental illness he had been
treated in a psychiatric
care facility and
the police are now still investigating
investigating his possible motive they
are not ruling out
an islamist motivation that there is one
eyewitness
who said that he was shouting allahu
akbar before he
attacked people but again all of this is
not confirmed yet we have to see
well speaking of witnesses and what have
people been saying there we know that
passers-by tried to stop the attacker
yeah this seems to be um a very uh
emotional part of the story that um
before the police were able to arrive
here at the scene and before the
attackers started to step people
in a department store right behind me
which you can see where the police are
now standing um
apparently people who by passes by try
to stop the man
by as we've heard in the report throwing
things at him
and very likely um some of the wounded
and maybe even the casualties
might be people who actually try to stop
the man um
attacking more people here on the ground
in wurzburg
all right elizabeth young speaking to us
from the bavarian town of wutzberg thank
you